Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors again. We're continuing our series of understanding your DNA
Finding the hidden causes of disease. I'll reiterate that I don't think the DNA is everything your environment probably trumps this
Times 10 but your DNA really starts to shine when you have environmental issues and
You just can't seem to get over it. This tends to be like the
B.C. link the stone that's typically left unturned
A lot of doctors don't fully understand it. I certainly don't and learning more every day
And I try to update you with information that I learned
And I hope it's helpful so that this presentation of the ones preceded it the ones that follow it to the ones that I'll do
Tell I die are to give you tools to be able to manage your health
By yourself with your local doctor with our help if we can't help you we know that
Our clinic is typically booked and it's I want to help as many people as we can so that's why we do this all this information is free
In order for me to give you a report in a supplement report recommendation
There's a fee for that and most of you have already paid that that's why you're watching this that you're trying to analyze your own DNA
That's why you're watching this and help understand why I gave you the supplement report
That's why you're watching this, but if somebody said to these
Videos or you just found them on YouTube or whatever
Congratulations, they're free of charge. I hope they bless you. Hope they help you
and
I hope they help you understand cover some hidden things and struggles that you're having share with your doctor the more doctors that understand
Understand reading D&A and reading 23 and B reports and such the better off. I think everybody's gonna be
So this presupposes again that you did your 23 and B if you're watching it for that purpose
If you don't go to 23 and B dot com and get their their best
Packages that they have
and
Said just the username and password follow the information on our website cuttersclitic.com there and
You're gonna learn a lot. So this presentation is about the Bethanian cycle your Bethanian pathway is
Really has the purpose of making Sam
Sam or Sammy is your main methyl transfer ace group in your body which controls about
several hundred functions in your body
So if you don't have methyl proper methyl group support that could be a
Huge issue that you the purpose of methyl groups is to turn on and off genes
So if you have excess gene function then you're gonna have issues if you have decreased gene function
You're gonna have issues and they typically all begin with a hypomethalation and
They can end up becoming a hyperbethylation. So you do it to be careful with supplementation
I hit that kind of hard on the last segment on the methylation piece
Because there tends to be some misinformation out there that
If you have a specific gene defect like a MTHFR gene defect you should instantly go
Head start using methyl groups like methyl tetrahedrifolate methyl comolamine
I don't go that pathway. I've seen too many mistakes that pathway because if you overbeth the late you will push the myopterid pathway
Which produce could produce excess serotonin excess dopamine excess
glutamate and
Epinephrine or epinephrine and you could have an emotional crisis on hand
So you want to look at the big picture
The farther you could move away from the subject and look at the big picture you're gonna get a better
Viewpoint of the whole thing. So hopefully you'll get that just through this thing and that piece of myopic
Any particular subject all of these are important the methanine cycle is so important
I've said it in the mitochondrial slides that
One of your life goals and your life purpose is this to make ATP well another life purpose is to make sami
So sami your made methyl transfer group it turns genes on it'll on it off controls hundreds of different functions within your body
If you don't do this you will be dead. So this is a life purpose. So stand up at the next step
Motivation group and you can tell people your life purpose is to make ATP and to make sami
and
Everybody will understand what you're talking about
So if you look at the lower left-hand quarter again. Thank you
Dr. Ben Lynch and seeking health for these nice pictures. I love their pictures
Do you if you watched the folate pathway the the
methylation video
That proceeded this
You'll remember this chart you probably haven't memorized already and it's easy peasy
But the main purpose of
folate in your body is to produce
methyl tetrahydrofolate which is
gives a methyl group in order to make sam
So it goes through the next bigger picture here
It goes through these genes
MTR and recycles B12 through MTRR and then goes on to make
Methiety at the top of that picture then through another gene family called the MAT gene family in order to make sam
And then that does a bunch of things and then finally goes down to make almost cystine and feeds downwards
Through the CBS pathway or the Transulferation pathway
To get rid of sulfates sulfites to make glutathione. That's where SOD is involved. That's where
Oxidation and reduction of
Different things in your body getting this is all part of your detoxification pathway all part of your
Metabolic pathways that create every function that goes on in your body
So we want to look a little bit specific at these as we go through these
I know it's a lot to consume if this is the first time you look at it. We're like what I am not I hate chemistry
I don't like the idea this well
You don't have to become a chemist or a geneticist just could follow me through this
I just want you to get kind of an idea
Oh what we're talking about and how
Ibrain works
So let's look at that circle at that arrow there
So from the folate pathway methell tetrahydrofolate enters this pathway and goes through this gene called
MTR every one of these genes. They're a little bubble of this beautifully
Put together diagram and that MTR is how you start to form
Methiety but it goes through this little inner circle here. See where it says cobalamine and then another type of cobalamine and it uses
Hydroxy groups and it makes through the MTR R gene and it makes methyl cobalamine and it cycles around so there's different
Forms of B12. This is B12. That's what cobalamines. There's different forms of B12
So depending upon a person's
genetic defects in this cycle and even more importantly in the biopteran cycle where you make
your
neurotransmitters which we won't get to write on this presentation
It's important to use
To supplement if you're going to supplement with B12 like here's the genes that we look at the
Overlapped picture here that's
That's a cutaway from your genetic slip report that I gave you this MTR this this particular person the MTR has no defect in their MTR
G and see so a hundred percent function there their MTR R gene they got a double allele defect so about
0% function you can't equate the percent but they have
the worst-case scenario that MTR G
MTR R gene so they don't recycle B12 very well
So the need for B12 is probably a parent with this person we need to use B12
But then the type of B12 is the next question that we need to ask so again this
alludes to my point of
Just because a person has a defect we're going to give this supplementation well you got to look at the big picture
So because this person has a defect it might be good to use B12
But what form of B12 should we use we want to look at the biopterate pathway?
So from this data that we have right here on this person I don't know what form of B12 to use yet
So what do I look at the biopterate pathway that I may say oh this person's got a bunch of
Comp defects and we'll see that later
So because they have comp defects we're not going to use methyl groups. We're not going to use methyl tetrahedral or methyl comolabene in this case so
The made forms of B12
Our methyl comolabene that's what you'll see most used and that's typically a good form of B12
Unless the person has defects in their biopterate pathway then you want to switch to something else
There's a deadisill comolabene which is another good form of B12
Hydroxy comolabene which is another good form of B12. I tend to use those two a little bit more than methyl comolabene
The person has biopterate defects and then there's cyano comolabene which in my opinion is not a good form of comolabene
So that's another way you could tell
If the supplement company really cares about the people taking the supplements
Remember I said in the last presentation are they using folic acid
Synthetic folic acid in their supplements if the answers yes then they really don't care
Are they using cyano comolabene they really don't care
So I don't let my patients take those supplements
So you shouldn't take them either
So you get a kind of a picture here. We want to look at how am I recycling B12? How am I using B12?
Really important because that's what makes
Ultimately a thiety
So
There's other things that block this gene
just like
Every other gene you might not hit like this person in this case in error did not have an MTR defect
Remember they had a double allele MTRR defect, but they did not have an MTR defect
However, there's environmental things that even trump this so all these things in purple at this giant, you know
brownish arrow
Block that MTR gene even though there's no genetic defects there one of those things diter coccyte
What's that? Well, that's the
Diter coccyte could be the byproduct of a chronic infection side okay inducible diter coccyte
So if I have chronic lime I'm going to have excess
uncoupled diter coccyte which is going to block my MTR gene
TB that's lead so heavy metal toxicity lead burkery toxicity
Here's again hydrogen peroxide isn't good to use hydro peroxide that's natural
I'm using a hydro peroxide approach I take on your peroxide to kill my
To kill my lime who well maybe that's not a good idea it blocks your pathways here. It blocks the MTR
I see an aldehyde from lime disease
Diteris oxide Diteris oxide is what you'd receive in the dentist chair
Never a good idea to get nitrous oxide get novocate don't get nitrous oxide. That's the gas that they'd give you
T and F alpha that's
Inflammatory cytokine so if I have any source of inflammation in my body I'm going to have a decrease
Recycling of B12 I'm going to have an increase need for B12
So in our report that we give you you have this piece that says all B12 factors now just strictly from a genetic point of view
These are B12 factors this person did not have any MTR defect
Okay, but they had a double-lil MTRR gene so they right there they have some need for increase B12
How do you get B12 well you get B12 mainly from your food right you get everything from your food
So you don't make B12 in your body you recycle that but you need a source of B12 it's an essential nutrient
So you get it what from red beets yes, but you have to absorb it
How do you absorb it it goes down to your gut you have to break it down?
So you have to have a healthy stomach acid right has to get into the
uh, a dewanda
Where you get intrinsic factor so B12 requires this extra step other than other nutrients in
Trinsic factor that's made in your body attaches to B12 to get you to absorb B12 well
If you have FUT2G defects you're going to have
Got issues you're going to have a decreased absorption of B12
If you have GIF gene that's a gene that makes intrinsic factor
Like this person has a single oleal gene and the TCN gene which help transport B12
This person has like almost every problem you could have in getting B12 into their body
So deficiency of B12 for this person is probably pretty high and don't be confused because you could
Do a B12 test to see my B12 is just fine, but it's not getting into the cells
So you're not recycling you're not getting into the cells the the type of B12 is so important as well
So I know it's super confusing
But there's sometimes that I will put on somebody supplement report that I'm going to recommend hydroxychabolamine or I'm going to recommend a dentisilchabolamine
Then they're like well how come I'm not taking methylchabolamine because my other doctor said I should take it because I have this defect
It's like well, I do have a reason behind everything that I'm doing. It's not just like throwing it out there
You understand you're supplement report. I am personally lucky that it making decisions that I may be wrong
Okay, but
It's not it's not just a cookie cutter approach. I'm making some decisions based upon information that I know and so
Just just know that and it doesn't mean that you do what your doctor does doesn't trump me and and they're seeing you and testing
I understand that but
There's reasons behind what I'm trying to do and that's what I've tried to convey in this
In this information in this series
Now the other pathways that makes Sam there's multiple pathways you see this big picture here
You can see there's multiple pathways where you're recycling things to make Sam because it's so important to make Sam
So we look at these other genes and how they are affected my ability to make Sam
So the more defects I have through all of these different genetic pathways. I'm gonna have a greater
need to support this
Follow me now symptom pictures of not making Sam
And not necessarily like I'm gonna have aches and pains or not necessarily then I gonna you know die of cancer right away
It's it's a little bit more obtuse because it does so many different functions
It's um, it's it's it's a broad brush-based picture that we have to paint when a person is not making enough Sam
So you want to look at all these genes and support which you can support
Okay, that makes sense
MATG is an important one
That we look at with people that it can
Ten to push to what kind of diet we want to give because a person that has
MATG defects is going to have excess about a methionine that's the
That's what metionine goes through this MATG to make Sam so if I have a lot of defects in MATG
This MAT1 gene I could have excess methionine and that can be a problem with cancer patients
and
My belief is that
cancers that are
There's certain cancers and go back and watch my
Under website. I have the cancer diet video and other cancer diet video. I talk about people with
MATG defects probably should cut down on the
Their methionine consumption because they have a lot of excess methionine already
And with specific cancer how it relates to that some cancers can feed off of specific amino acids
Typically methionine and glutamine so
Cancer patients that have a lot of MATG defects and I would consider this a lot of this picture right here
I put them on a lower methionine diet. Sometimes they put them on what I call the low-bethionine diet
Which is really basically a
Extremely low protein similar to a vegan diet
But if people don't have cancer and you have a G defect like this
I would say still maybe maybe you should not be as big of a meter
You know, it partly whether a person should be a
Eat less meat or a more meat depends on this gene right here
But it also depends on your biopter and pathway and how that is affecting your emotions too
And we'll talk about that in a later presentation
but
To summarize people with a lot of MATG's
By what I consider eating less protein
Got it people with a lot of MATG defects by what I consider eating less protein doesn't mean you cut it on all together
But see how you do see how you feel going on a
lower protein diet
And this goes back to I am not an advocate of everybody should be a vegan or everybody should be a vegetarian or everybody should eat paleo
Because everybody's genes are different
Okay, so you might do really well on a paleo diet somebody else might do really well on a vegan diet very different diets
So part of it I really believe has to do with your gene so looking at that can help guide that
Um, there's other things that block the MATG. So here again the things in purple very similar to what we saw before
Chronic infections is the biggest thing chronic infections
Toxicity's could block these genes. I should say too that chronic stress just about blocks all your genes
So you need to light up a little bit and have fun at life and not take things so serious too
But dealing with environmental factors I've said before and again
Typically trumps the genes we will really if if you're only going to look at your genes and hope that
You know getting this analysis done by me is going to solve all your problems
Think little off-face you have to deal with the environmental things and hopefully you're doing that with your local doctor as well
Dealing with a chronic infection or parasitic infection or dealing with the toxicity
Um, but certainly understanding your detox pathways and these pathways could be just a blessing and be that missing link
Again, you're
Duetogenic review with us
Um, and I hope this is a blessing to you
That's really what our prayers because we can't help everybody. We just can't see everybody
If a person does want to see us they have to go to our website under the first steps and follow all that
They could read about other website. We put all our fees on there too. We just want to be completely upfront
So read that and you can make some decisions that are going to be best for you that way
Here's your 23-and-be agreements
Understand I can only make the recommendations based upon
You know what we see in your genes make sure you bring it to your doctor and confirm it and test the supplements
Whatever you need to do. That's going to be best for you. This is the kind of reports you're going to get
Again, I hope this was a blessing and um, I hope you are blessed and um and that um
Uh, you're getting all the help you possibly kid. That's oh, that's our prayer. Bye. Bye. Bye